uh what's first of all next For You
music wise you're working this album I'm
sure there's more music videos coming
are you already recording new [ __ ] oh
yeah it's already in a clip I'm dropping
top of the Year already and I'm gonna
let y'all wait two years for no nothing
no more yeah yeah it was a long way yeah
why the way
um well it was a lot that happened
obviously like it was mid pandemic so it
was a lot of things that needed to be
worked out with that but I just think
now like I'm just more Hands-On with my
[ __ ] I'm more in charge of my [ __ ] like
even when it came down from everything
from like my
um rollout you know I had my team or
whatever so shout out to them but you
know my mixes to the content that I was
dropping to my feature like to
everything like you know I'm really more
so Hands-On with mine and I think that
that's important for a lot of women to
do just be in charge of your own [ __ ]
for the first album where you're not
like as Hands-On well the first album
was kind of shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
galaxies always [ __ ] see that's why
you need an iPhone I got both oh it's
okay talk heavy not bad the first one
was really like cut and dry was super
easy I didn't obviously
um have as much of a rollout as I did
with this one but I recorded um that
lives in about seven days not even seven
days three days I told West I was gonna
give him seven days because I was scared
to come outside after I got covered and
then
um well you recorded the first album in
three days yeah wow yeah we drove to
what we call the five is in Atlanta and
it's like in the basement in one of West
houses and it's like super grimy like
um don't watch TV Travis He um did like
most of the graffiti artwork in here got
all the artwork up there they got like a
green light that's like super muddy and
it's just a Vibe so I gave myself seven
days to do it I left in three because I
had my Boutique that had just started
and I needed to get back to that check
you out
and um you know long story short you
know when it was time to like package up
everything you know West kind of like
handled everything with that even with
some of the Beats I was doing I didn't
even know my first single was a Primo
beat until after I had recorded it
because it didn't have no scratches on
it oh you didn't know you didn't know
you were rapping on a Premiere no he was
because it didn't have no scratch you
know right yeah he's got the hooks yeah
he was just like after I recorded it we
listened back to it
he was like okay I'm gonna send this to
Primo so you can put the scratches on
and I turn around I'm like DJ Premiere
yeah which Primo are we talking about
yeah I'm like nah let me do it over
again he was like nah it sounds amazing
like that was one project where it was
like
I didn't do a lot of singing on it or
anything like that it was just pretty
much like
bars and you know as far as like the
concept and everything like that like
Wes did it and it's this time around it
was like okay well I wanted to be more
like female empowerment I wanted to be
more like me like telling my story for
real I wanted to open up on different
songs that's why you got songs like El
Puro with me and Conway going back and
forth once I'm like almost like a
relationship type of song you know I'm
singing a lot more on it I mean I got a
song called First Wives Club on it
that's literally saying like [ __ ] I'm
not your [ __ ] so but the guys love it